[Music]
in h08 nightmare news
oh [ __ ] amy yeah is there any toy
dream out there
no i feel like there is i wanna know
where
there's gotta be one where like people
no
people are petty and no i think it's a
dream for people
who are super like uptight they love the
hoa
and they want a power trip somewhere
maybe they're the ones that are
controlling the hoa that's when it's a
dream
yeah yeah it's usually people that get
stepped on
at work and they want a power trip
somewhere so they are like oh i'll be
the whatever executive commissioner for
this one and they're like no one gets to
grow their grass over three inches
i want to live in a junkyard like
stephen avery and then it doesn't matter
that's how we are not living in a
junkyard you're so lucky
i'm sorry we're not did you see how big
his lot is
that doesn't matter it's all trash you
didn't think that was cool
no you don't want a dirt bike in your
front yard
you look like you want one i would love
to dirt bike and ride atvs on my phone
live next to a quarry
why did i get with you of all people you
want to bring me back to my white trash
roots and i'm trying to get away from
that's probably why you got with him
because something inside of you wants
that
hold on to that wait what's what's white
trash about living in a junk yard and
living by a quarry
right that's a business owner
can we move on i'm sad uh somebody might
play a player
play a play a player no it's not it's
player player yeah it's playing
yeah uh a man finally won a four-year
battle and what he calls the war on
christians
what hell yeah oh can i guess
what kind of devil worshiper just
because he didn't want to put up um
he didn't want to put up [ __ ] about
christianity
no he wanted to put up [ __ ] about it i
bet oh then i bet you
she was guessing i bet
i bet you it was baby jesus and the
three wise men
and mother mary on the [ __ ] lawn
or something like that or it was snowman
with a bible mr frosty the snowman with
a [ __ ] bible
oh and they said hey joey said you can't
do that yeah they're like we are
[ __ ] satanists here at this community
or they could just be like jewish or
something else and so they're like okay
quiet down your christianity or they
could be like can you take down your
aborted fetus decorations
this is a war on christians wow
yeah so this man his name is jeremy he's
from idaho
and his his hoa
has been trying to block his christmas
displays
since 2015. are they aborted fetus
no it's not something crazy like that
it's just like he goes all out like this
is his house
oh [ __ ] yeah that's so dumb
that [ __ ] looks like a vegas casino how
did he do that how long does that take
that is fascinating i love it
i want to do that this was started in
july probably yeah
we were we were binge watching on
youtube and netflix and all this stuff
about
christmas house decorations and the wars
that go behind it
and some people take it so serious that
they start from july
wow oh for real that's a real thing i
absolutely love it
and on youtube you can see a compilation
of the best
christmas decorations there's like one
where like it plays
music and then like these [ __ ] led
lights come out like a rave
and then there's little santas that are
[ __ ] mouthing the words of the song
it's crazy yeah what's the electricity
bill on that fool's house
i know right it's pretty crazy so this
guy
oh this is germany by the way
and then so how is that a war on
christians
all right so this all started before
they even moved in
they sent a letter to the hoa letting
them know like hey
we go all out for christmas just letting
you know we're in the process of buying
this house that's very courteous of that
that is courteous
and then so because we never do that
when we move then they're like oh uh
do you guys have any loud pets no no no
no no no no no no did we move in our
[ __ ]
parking lot no we didn't do that we're
not those people
we do try to keep things hush-hush i
always like when they ask me a question
you do not keep it i always
i always dilute it i always go like oh
yeah yeah but why do you want to know
and then i try to figure out why they
want to know that so i can feed him my
answer you wish you were that slick but
you're
not you're oh you're the only neighbor
that is the loudest like every single
morning
at 7 a.m it's him and joe and like all
his other friends blasting music
[ __ ] doing karate but they know we're
gonna be protectors of the neighborhood
oh i can't wait for all guys show we're
not gonna get our balls [ __ ] busted
like this [ __ ] no
every time i have nikki here too i'm
like oh i wanna tell you a story about
this and she's like i'm busting your
[ __ ] balls right now and i'm like oh
god damn it i'll [ __ ] hurt
and he didn't mean hush hush in the way
of being quiet
he's being secretive yeah to people that
want to tell him
you know i got it i try to be harmony i
got it i just wanted to talk [ __ ]
exactly exactly i'm trying to hold on to
any little thing to segue to the [ __ ]
talking come on
yeah so when this guy sent the letter to
hoa when they were buying the home they
sent a letter back
saying that the lights and the noise oh
by the way i forgot to mention his whole
christmas celebration thing
it's five days leading up to christmas
like he'll have people come over and
like celebrate and all this stuff and
like he goes all out
and he also raises money for charity
during that time so then
um yeah i feel like a cool guy
i wish there was one of these guys in
our community and i go through the house
and party
yeah dude i wish i could be the hoa guy
seeing his lit up house and being like
with her sunglasses on it's too [ __ ]
bright in here
i can't go to sleep it's like it's like
that uh national lampoon's bit with the
julie louise dreyfus and her husband in
the movie
i don't remember that [ __ ] oh yeah sorry
just the season to watch this [ __ ] i
guess
i always want to see the bothered
people's point of view
yeah like well she might tell us about
to try to tell you i'm like
i wish we had that info yeah me too
could they never add that
part in never so we finally get that
we could just sit here and guess for
another 15 minutes that's what happens
in every video and i'm just here like
that
that i could tell you okay so anyway so
then they said that they were
concerned or specifically that they were
hesitant to mention
that some of the town's residents are
non-christians or of another faith and
i don't even want to think of the
problems i could bring up
so then they said that right and so that
immediately
just had jeremy feel like this was
against
them being christian and it just started
this whole thing so he's a lawyer and so
he decided oh he got the time
they spoke to the wrong man well i don't
know
any muslim or jewish person that's
actually against christmas lights
yeah i've never heard of that before
well i mean this specific hoa person
what they ended up doing was
by saying that they also um
they pretty much violated the fair
housing act
and so that's why jeremy was awarded
seventy five thousand dollars in
punitive damages
he basically paid himself because he was
like he was like honestly like you can
reword what it says in that letter to be
like
oh you know um there are this family
this whole community is nothing but why
people and so we're hesitant that like
other people you know like they could
totally reword it words
discriminatory yeah exactly it's
discriminatory so because of that
that's why you want it i love
hoas get in the business what if it's
just like one vietnamese family
and they're like well we don't know that
those buddhists will be cool with it
right
and then they're like i don't care but
it's like they
you know how like they try to blame
other people but it's like they're the
ones
that's like the white like you scream
racism and stuff and i'm always like
huh you know what i mean like they're
like i want to stand up for black people
right now because they don't have a
voice and i'm giving them a voice with
my white voice yeah and they're like i
don't give a [ __ ]
everyone's like i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] and then they're like
okay but you should hey why don't you
give a [ __ ] this is about you
then they get mad because you don't get
[ __ ] i love these people
yeah and so yeah it's pretty funny
because they won 60 thousand dollars in
conference
conference compensatory thank you
we should put it all in the lights every
[ __ ] dollar in the lights baby
yeah i do yeah they need a big ass santa
with all the reindeer dasher dancer
prancer vixen the whole
not rudolph because he's copyrighted we
can't get rude off true you can't get
them
you can't give them i didn't know that
christmas lights or any of that
celebrating christmas was a christian
thing
i had no idea it was connected to
christianity that's why
people say happy holidays now too
because not everybody says that's the
war on christmas
cause the cr the christian christmas is
the stable with the three wise men
that's christmas this is his birthday
yeah yeah but that's not even his real
birthday
the lights and the candy canes and the
snowmen like that's not
christian it's in the bible have you
read the bible yes do you read about the
frosty the snowman
oh yeah leviticus yeah yeah
he was a canaanite oh my gosh
exactly they don't even know
that's that's that reminds me of when um
starbucks decided to change their cups
and people were like that's unchristian
like man and it's like how the [ __ ]
does red and green have anything to do
with christianity
the vatican city that's their color red
and green yeah the whole thing
the whole thing you should see vatican
city at christmas dude they
oh i want to go there's frosty snowman
everywhere candy canes if rudolph is all
up in it that's [ __ ]
there's rudolph with a [ __ ] bible and
[ __ ] yeah dude that's christian
dude they have a 40 foot tall santa
drinking a coca-cola
yeah vatican that's really cool they got
polar bears in [ __ ] slays and [ __ ]
that's some crazy ass i don't know man
people are just dumb
mm-hmm that's why it's kind of funny
that they won because it was like
it's only because that one line in the
letter too like if she just didn't or
whoever wrote that hoa letter didn't say
oh and i'm hesitant to say
it's because you're shoving your
christianity down her throat like oh you
could have saved
the association 60 grand it's because
they wanted to be passive aggressive
about it or like
they wanted it i guess they want to
leave those stupid remarks the only
reason this is how [ __ ] petty i am
sometimes
uh it's like i i kind of regret not
going to law school because
i just want to fight people like legally
yeah you should be like ha ha
[ __ ] you i win it's like geo in this
conversation
i'm going to get an injunction you know
what i mean and i'm like oh [ __ ] i don't
want to deal with a lawyer
all right here i'll just pay you to go
away who are lawyers afraid of because
cops are afraid of lawyers all that do
you think they're afraid of the mafia
judges supreme court judges i'm just
wondering yeah maybe
lawyers are [ __ ] untouchable because
there's lawyers and then cops don't want
to mess with them anybody
there's that i think lawyers are scared
of
physical violence because they can they
can do because they could do verb
well okay so if you're a lawyer right
yeah you're you're you go to a
verbal war with people right logical war
with people
but if someone comes to your house with
the machete and they blindfold your ass
conjunction they better kill you because
then you can fight back
well just because they're smart they're
just gonna call the cops yeah yeah
or they cut off one of the fingers to
like one of your pets
i just love the idea that this guy's an
attorney who does a lot like he's he's
with his client and he's like he's like
we're gonna get we're gonna get the
[ __ ] kids from your husband we're
gonna [ __ ] him so hard
he's not gonna have a dime next
christmas if he wants to [ __ ] with me
he's
going to war pal and then he goes home
and he's like 60 000 likes he's like i
[ __ ] love christmas
and he's like oh honey can you make the
eggnog he's like oh it's a little hot
it's a lovely day that's kind of like us
yep
hypocrites through and through those are
my people when i hear hypocrites i'm
like
my people hypocrite i'm home that's why
we take the hypocrite oath
that's it
[Music]